coutume d'été sur la vaste plage de
santander les courses paysanne qui s'y
déroule comme un derby rustique
puis son jockey monté sur deux robustes
montures sont naturellement loin de
faire songer rallonge un ymca
mais le coeur y est
courses de chars ont aussi leur place au
cours de ce festival du percheron mais
là aussi ce sont des chevaux de tous les
jours a trait à leurs charrettes
quotidienne rien des performances
décoratives et sportive de ben-hur
et tout cela joyeux animé vivant comme
le tableau inconnu d'une chevauchée
rustique à la mode espagnole
la victoire est comme toutes les
victoires solennellement cours année
[Applaudissements]
chaque année durant quinze jours les
lacs de la frise en landes s'offre aux
courses de voiliers mais c'est un
spectacle qui n'a qu'une parenté
lointaine avec les modern art et gap
les bâtiments en lice les transbordeurs
qu'on utilisait autrefois dans la
province ne sont pas précisément doué
d'une exquise légèreté mais leur
évolution y gagnent en majesté
et comme l'ont fait leurs pères leurs
grands airs et leur arrière-grand-père
les frisons qui ont gardé intact le goût
de l'ancien navigation à voile se
livrent chaque année pour le sport et
pour le plaisir à ce tranquille
championne
les championnats d'allemagne de ski
nautique elles se sont déroulées sur la
moselle
l'élite des skieurs allemands se prépare
est ici au championnat d'europe où ils
seront des concurrents redoutables et
plus loin peut-être à la rencontre de
miami où auront lieu les championnats du
monde
la jeune et jolie championne ne valent
pas au niveau galles qui l'a emporté
dans le slalom comme dans les figures a
montré une parfaite maîtrise et sera
certainement l'une des compétitrices les
plus en vue dans le prochain tournoi
européen
il nous faut du nouveau nom futile plus
au monde s'écriait naguère un poème
l'ars a fait sien ce cri de guerre et
dans son atelier de métal au sculpteur
medcalf s'efforce de donner un sens
nouveau à la matière niki de saint
phalle elle fait de la peinture c'est à
dire qu'elle a enfoui des sachets de
couleur sous une couche de plâtre après
quoi il ne reste plus qu'à libérer la
couleur à la carabine
[Musique]
pourquoi pas il y en a bien qui peignent
au pistolet
[Musique]
et voilà
tingle y est d'une autre école celle des
mobiles mais ces mobiles à lui sont des
mobiles sonore ces méthodes unissent à
la fois la vision de l'artiste et le
manuel du petit bricoleur c'est pourquoi
on retrouve dans ses créations les
objets les plus usuelles et les plus
hétéroclites exemple nous avons enfin le
mobile musical qu'en pensez vous
abidjan qui célébrait le premier
anniversaire de l'indépendance de la
côte d'ivoire a été pour deux jours le
lieu de rendez-vous du monde entier
nouveau palais de la présidence vaste
édifice ultramoderne battu en huit mois
monsieur houphouët boigny a accueilli en
effet avec le frère du président kennedy
et le représentant de l'urss des
personnalités venues de tous les
continents
la république de côte d'ivoire devait
présenter à ses invités au nombre
desquels se trouvaient le président de
la république sénégalaise
monsieur léopold senghor et monsieur
michel debré premier ministre français
un résumé des forces vives de la nation
à l'occasion d'un grand défilé où
devaient figurer avec la jeune armée
les organisations économiques et
sociales ivoirienne trois mille hommes
des différentes armes ont déclenché
l'enthousiasmé général
on a pu découvrir les premiers éléments
d'une marine entretenait à leur suite
les formations politiques sportives
syndicales et économiques ont évoqué les
chances d'une nation qui n'est il y a
tout juste un an
regarde résolument vers l'avenir
nouvelle crise de berlin a déclenché
dans la zone occidentale de l'ex
capitale allemande un subite
accroissement du nombre des transfuges
qui depuis 1945 ne cesse de franchir des
stands ouest le rideau de fer
alors que le nombre de ces transfuges de
l'est flottaient autour de 4000 par
semaine il s'est soudain élevé à 15
cents nm à 2000 par jour
ces réfugiés qui ont tout quitté sans
venu les mains vides
les services d'accueil de l'ouest sont
donc dans la nécessité de pourvoir à
leurs besoins et de leur fournir les
objets de première nécessité du centre
d'hébergement ils sont ensuite dirigés
vers l'allemagne fédérale où les
services de reclassement s'occupant
d'eux hémorragie sans fin pour
l'allemagne de l'est problème pour
l'allemagne fédérale depuis quinze ans
plus de deux millions d'allemands sont
ainsi passés d'est en ouest
m
arrivée d'un iliouchine 18 à l'aérodrome
devenu covo waternet avec monsieur coach
of la famille du deuxième cosmonaute
soviétique a manqué pour moscou le début
de la journée type of l'homme qui a fait
dix sept fois le tour de la terre en 25
heures a franchi au pas de charge la
distance qui le séparait de la tribune
officielle et se devaient être geste
pour gest la répétition de la réception
qu'avait connu youri gagarine
des brins de monsieur tout sauf germann
qui peuvent passer tour à tour dans ceux
de son épouse tamara de sa soeur de sa
mère et de son thème
et enfin de youri gagarine
[Musique]
moscou allait pouvoir à son tour a clamé
son héros et lui faire le plus large
triomphe
c'était jour férié dans la capitale
soviétique et 2 millions de moscovites
sont passés sur la place rouge ce jour
là sous le portrait de lénine
on appréciera sans doute pas que
monsieur coach m'a fait profiter de
cette journée pour évoquer la menace
d'une super d'onde capable d'anéantir le
monde mais on applaudira sans réserve au
nouveau pas qui vient d'être accompli
dans la conquête de l'espace et que
symboliste un simple de visage jeune et
souriant
[Musique]